good morning from Hoda Kotb and Jenna
Bush Hager let's go y'all Hager made her
debut as co-host of the ten o'clock hour
of The Today Show on Monday and kicked
off the show holding hands with copy as
she headed to the stage and in honor of
the milestone copy presented her new
co-host with a special gift that is so
sweet
can you read yours anyway so now it's
official how many glasses of wine did
you have on your first day we today we
six yes we'll see wait wait too late
yeah way to win it the 37 year old
explained just how excited she was for
the new gig and how it affected her
sleep schedule I got really high cuz you
could his sleigh yes because today was
the first every said he was about to
tranquilize me and then I fell asleep
then there was this sweet moment a video
message from Hagar's dad george w bush
mom Laura Bush and her mother-in-law hey
Jenna your old dad here on film to tell
you how much I love you and how proud I
am of you I'll know you do a fabulous
job Jenna your mother and your mother
we're calling to say we're so proud of I
just feel so lucky I really do
I am surrounded with people I love I
work with people I love I have a family
that has always loved me unconditionally
even when I wasn't perfect or anywhere
close and just wait till you get a load
of this cuteness
that's her hubby Henry and their two
daughters who surprised their mama with
some roses I have two little girls who
light up my life and a husband that
supports me unconditionally so like well
there's that it's been that day et was
with Hagar and copy after filming
wrapped she hit it out of the park and
Hagar revealed the sweet gift Kathie Lee
Gifford gave her Kathie Lee left me a
little note and a present in the
dressing room that was hers and she left
me a bracelet that said your joy is
non-negotiable Gifford announced in
early December that she was leaving the
morning show after 11 years she's taught
us all really by example to be gracious
and generous and hilarious all things
that I hope I can and can continue on
[Music]